[Music]
heavy-ish topic here
oh this is so heavy you can lift apart
you guys have heard
of brianna taylor right who's brianna
taylor so
for those of you that haven't heard her
name that's not ken's girlfriend right
that's brianna okay okay so
uh brianna she was shot
and killed by police in her own home oh
my god
asleep on march 13th just after
midnight police were conducting a
narcotics investigation
um like no knock warrant
should be banned which we'll get there
so i don't even know they could do that
you can yeah it's [ __ ] nuts
cause i thought that was only like so i
know there's certain i guess
um authorities that local police have
and i thought like that kind of [ __ ] is
only like federal like fbi and above can
do [ __ ] like that oh
like they say the reasons for that it's
like so you don't like tamper with
evidence or you don't do all these
things and like try to like destroy it
yeah before they come in but the idea is
innocent until proven guilty
[ __ ]
yeah so police when they conduct these
no no knock raids which has expanded
significantly since the 1990s during the
war on drugs yeah i thought it was only
dea
atf fbi like cia type [ __ ] so yeah well
police what they do is they use military
gear
including flashbang grenades battering
rams and automatic weapons
in an effort to disorient and confuse
their targets
so that's that's like what they do when
they bust in right remember the picture
of elon elian gonzalez
like in florida like this little cuban
kid
is getting taken from his uh uncle and
aunt or whatever
and they have a [ __ ] like full-on
carbine like in his face like it's
like why to go get a little kid from
home yeah that's crazy
so on march 13th that's when they just
burst in
briana's apartment uh she was 26 years
old
a black woman and an emergency medical
technician and so her boyfriend 27 year
old kenneth
he immediately retrieved a gun and shot
at the officers because he thought that
they were intruders
and they were yeah no knock warrant they
were intruders exactly
um so there are witnesses uh
brianna's family and like neighbors and
even the boyfriend saying like they did
not announce themselves
like they [ __ ] didn't like that's why
he was shooting to protect
what they claim they did that's what's
[ __ ] exactly
so brianna was hit at least eight times
killing her and so since
this has happened there have been you
know a lot of
petitions out there calling for this no
knock warrants to be banned
and now recently louisville
metro council announced that they have
banned the no knock raids okay so
they're calling it brianna's law
that's something that's awesome well
this was also with or
correct me if i'm wrong the they got the
wrong address
and the people that were out there
actually looking for were already in
custody
so i didn't hear that part but i did i
did read that
um that the location of where they were
actually selling drugs and stuff or
these two men were accused of selling
drugs
that location was more than 10 miles
away
but brianna's apartment was included in
the warrant because they believed that
that
that it was used to receive drugs as
part of the operation but they didn't
find any drugs in the apartment
i knew they said that the the people
that were involved the two guys they
were looking for were already
i heard that did you hear what happened
to jay pharaoh from snl yeah
yes yeah crazy what happened to he's
just
uh working out outside wearing
sweatpants or whatever in l.a
in l.a and uh officer comes up to him
and he's like put your hands like on
your side like put your hands out like a
plane or whatever
and then uh jay farrell like gets put on
the ground and has an officer put his
knee on his neck for like four minutes i
guess
something like that yeah something like
that and basically the idea was that
they just said like hey we're looking
for for a black male with your
description wearing gray sweatpants in
this area and so they treated him like
that because of that like it's [ __ ]
crazy right and then he said
um say he was like and he was like yo go
google
j phil right now and you will feel so
dumb or whatever you said and then
and then they were like oh okay sorry we
thought you were someone else there was
a guy that died yesterday
uh was like same thing he was like i
can't breathe and the officer said i
don't care
and then he died like minutes later what
yeah and there's still a little
happening there's still a big
push like because they haven't charged
any officers with anything for beyond
taylor
uh situations so that's what a lot of
the people that were protest protesting
they're also pushing for that
if you're gonna ban that law because
that happened that means
something bad happened and those
officers should be charged exactly
otherwise it's like they kind of they
probably get protected under the fact
that at the time this was legal
we could have done this and there's
still but it should be investigated
that's the thing that's the thing like
so they're trying to do like a
like a their word against our type thing
because if they're saying they announce
themselves
right yeah but after armada our berry
real quick like we're
obviously there was a former police
officer involved and then they
locally worked to cover up the situation
until months later when outrage happened
and then they're like okay we're
investigating science fine it's fine
look
look so yeah like it literally takes
people screaming down the street
to [ __ ] get some justice like it's
ridiculous especially as like
with the no knock stuff it's like as a
gun owner you have a gun to protect
yourself
against these things mostly you know um
to where if you just start hearing
people break into your house
and i would start shooting immediately
if i heard people break into my house i
would start shooting
at wherever i hear the sound coming from
i had a camera go off the other night
because i have cameras on my [ __ ] and i
had a camera the other night and i went
for my gun and then i checked the camera
and it was my cat
but i was ready to [ __ ] go music
video
um uh the neighbors one where and then
he basically all the whole video was
just police raiding his house right um
so breaking into his house and then i
guess after it when they realized like
nobody was home and stuff they started
looking there's cameras everywhere
uh and they literally in the video come
and start uh
ripping the cameras down off of the
walls yeah you know you're literally
just tampering with that evidence
exactly in a crime scene brianna's
boyfriend
so he was initially charged with
attempted murder
of an officer because he shot one in the
leg
but then later he got shot also and
survived so
so with these no knock warrants like
when they bust in do they have to say
police
like do they immediately they're
supposed to supposed to but they
didn't they're supposed to identify
themselves as they come into wherever
they're they're going but they but
the eyewitnesses said it didn't happen
and then it's like their word versus
their word
right yeah so then now the
the new like procedures they're saying
that law enforcement officers
serving future warrants they have to
knock
they have to identify themselves as law
enforcement in a manner that can be
heard by the occupants
and then it says that police might must
wait
at least 15 seconds or for a reasonable
reasonable amount of time for occupants
to respond whichever is greater
before entering but even there man what
is that
so i so okay so 15 seconds like
if i'm phone if i'm asleep like are you
what are you pooping
at anything i think like any of those
subjective
like when you put the decision in the
cop's hands and his heart is
yeah it's it's no good it's no they also
said though that
uh it mandates the use of body cameras
throughout the entire process of serving
a warrant
if they wanted to do like this is my
maybe extreme but like with tampering of
evidence and stuff like that maybe like
shut off gas shut off water surround the
house so you can't you can see if
someone
is escaping or not and then with
megaphones and everything lights
be like hey we're here oh so much effort
or saving someone's life how about this
why can't cops turn off body cameras
because i used to work i used to work at
a place with a very stingy guy who was
like the boss
and he used to have a camera at every
angle the office to make sure you're not
[ __ ] around the internet or whatever
and so we all had to deal with that why
can't cops
why can cops turn off their body camera
if they want to why can they turn it off
yeah then it's like
what is the point yeah well i think they
have to turn it on
no but you're able to turn it on and off
like i guess they're saying it's like
just keep it on always yeah why can you
power it off like like i know vegas pd
did that
during all the protests during all
through a lot of that [ __ ]
so yeah luckily you know because like
isn't it like when you turn them off
they're still record for like another 30
seconds or something yeah when you turn
it on it doesn't have audio for 30
seconds but it
previously records the past 30 seconds
so it's constantly like overlapping or
rolling
but you have to click record to record
that incident right we have the tech to
constantly record a cop for an eight
hour oh for sure or even over time like
12-hour shift
like people are live streaming all the
time these days
but even like storage right like all
that stuff we we have the capability to
do all that
and if they do if they something happens
with the police officer they
have to like write a report or something
happens when they call in that
that whole day should just be archived
yeah exactly yeah it should all just be
going to like um
like a live little database you know
always just getting recorded at all
times cause they have the live
uh police radios where people could tune
in and then they even heard like
the police saying like um oh like shoot
them run them over like 10 for a mexican
24 black guy
yeah and then i don't know like if their
excuse could probably be like oh that's
just too much footage to look through
it's too much work
okay then volunteers i mean facebook
does it
like to review things that get flagged
but it's also like oh it's too much work
okay so just continue killing people
like but yeah so
with jay pharaoh too though like he
actually did a whole
piece on his instagram i saw that's
where i learned about all this
right or i'm like dude and it's so
heartbreaking where you could hear him
say
in the video like i could have been
george floyd
and he could have been yeah if a cop
goes i could put my neck
on on i can put my my knee on this guy's
neck
that's part of procedure it could happen
anywhere at any time
i don't why do they put it on for so
long i don't understand what the [ __ ]
they're trying to do
especially right now like i feel like
with all this going on why would you
even
like risk someone seeing you well this
happened months ago this happened months
before
oh did it oh it happened really near i
think i remember him saying that it
happened like near
right before okay but it was before the
george floyd thing but still it doesn't
matter it's not okay it's just
that that's why i think it was
part of procedure even dave chappelle
talked about it in his thing where like
the cop who had
ended up killing someone else the very
next day like he had just pulled
over dave chappelle like right before
and he
let him off with the warning probably
because he's a celebrity so he was able
to have that but then the very next day
that very same cop
ends up like killing have you guys ever
been arrested before
no no so they're very aggressive right
and so i asked like a couple cop friends
like why are you so aggressive
and the reason why they have to like
manhandle you and grab your wrist and
then almost like
it almost feels like they're tweaking
your shoulders to put their arms behind
you
and it's more of like a dominance thing
because
statistics show if i handle this guy
loosely
statistics have shown that people will
just take off and run off because they
don't feel like oh [ __ ] someone's
starting dominance
so i understand a little bit why they
kind of have to go i'm the one
in control with my body like body
language wise right like put you against
the hood
why i have to do these things where
they're even just so aggressive with
their tone like even when i'm getting
pulled because if you're too nice
there's statistics show people take over
and like [ __ ] you and it be and it
becomes a bigger situation
if they don't do it so that then i'm not
just find the knee uh
on the neck because i think that's
completely wrong but like
like i think it's a it's a police
officer's job to
de-escalate as quickly and as fast i
mean as quickly as possible
so like the minute you have someone in
your control like why are they
but even like a slam on the hood feels
aggressive though yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you know what i'm saying because that
makes you want to be like yo what the
[ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're like trying to do
something so they resist the rest and
they can like
use more force and like the guy that
there's that too that's how it feels
right yeah does that say it was the
video of the guy that was uh
in the hallway crawling and the officers
yelling the most like ridiculous
commands yeah
and he shoots the guy and even on his
gun he has like
inscribed like [ __ ] yeah or something
like where he's like looking for
something and it's like
they they there's a hundred percent
people that just became cops to
use excessive force and [ __ ] who
attracts the [ __ ] right you watch
how many cop movies do you watch where
it's a bad cop
right and like they're kind of bleed the
line between good and bad
so it's kind of sexy to be kind of a bad
cop and like you watch
jack bauer [ __ ] up everyone's civil
liberties and like we're all kind of
like yeah [ __ ] yeah it's tight
but like that's not like it it just
attracts the wrong people to these kinds
of professions i think
[Music]
you